attack on titan season 4 part 1 has
finished
which i'm sure is sad for most of us
that we'll have to wait until winter
2022 to see the invasion of paradise
island
another clash of the titans which i mean
it's really just aaron vs like
every other titan except zeke but and
even though the last few episodes were
extremely exciting and full of great
moments what i thought was
easily the most important among it all
was zeke's story
how more so than most if not all of the
other characters in attack on titan
since the very start since he was only a
pea-sized kid
zeke has been burdened with the
knowledge of both eldians and
marlians as well as carrying that burden
on his shoulders as an inheritor of
royal blood
i think that zeke's character beyond
being a villain or a titan or the
planner of the euthanization plan
he's meant to embody what free will is
in the world of attack on titan
a world where this idea isn't something
that many people can truly embody or
understand something that aaron brings
up in the last few episodes is how
neither armin nor mikasa have ever truly
had a free will of their own
armin has lost a piece of himself to
bertholds and the previous colossal
titans
and mikasa has been tied to aaron's
command since the moment she met him
and though it can certainly be argued
that both of these especially the latter
are just false
or subjective on aaron's part i'm not
really trying to explain the
specificities of this
the whole world of attack on titan is
this birdcage
it's a place where people are trapped
and forced into repeating history
over and over because i mean they know
no better
the cycle of hatred it all contributes
to this lack of free will that aaron
despises and mentions
and i think that zeke most of all is the
one character who was written in a way
by isayama to specifically
seem free i do want to note though that
this is just my take on isaiah's writing
and my take on a pretty important theme
in attack on titan overall
also if you're part of the 97 of my
viewers who aren't subbed yet
it'd be awesome if you could like and
hit that sub button roll the intro
i think first it's important to define
what free will is
and though the real definition is
important i intend more to focus on how
it's crafted within the world of attack
on titan
and i want to clarify this because i
don't want to make it seem like no one
in the world except zeke
is acting of their own accord but
instead look at how isayama has made
these characters on a macro scale
embody history repeating itself and how
they were written to demonstrate the
difficulty in becoming truly free of
that birdcage
anyway free will is the power of acting
without the constraint of necessity or
fate
the latter of which i think is far more
relevant in attack on titan
fate destiny from the start this has
been a vital conflict in attack on titan
will mankind accept their fate and
resign themselves to the walls
will they let the enemy come to them or
will they take it into their own hands
and fight the titans that surround them
take the offensive and finally retake
what is theirs
throughout seasons 1 and 2 we
essentially saw our main cast
let the enemy come to them always annie
invaded in season 1
reiner and burt holt in season 2. it
wasn't really until season 3 that we
began to see the idea of proactivity
and by extent free will and the
initiative to act before something
happens
instead of waiting to respond to it
which is a way that they were growing
out of that fatalistic mindset
the scouts put their complex plan into
motion to remove the corrupt government
and in part two made an organized and
voluntary effort to take back
shiganshina finally
we see the reversal of roles here where
marley and reiner and berdholz went from
being the aggressors to being the
aggressed
they were the ones who were pushed back
now which does seem like free will
like our characters on a macro scale are
moving forward
but then our horizons rapidly expand
with the reveal from the basement and
onset of season 4
where we realize that this cycle of
going from being the victim to the
aggressor and back and forth
is not new or free at all but something
that has been seen
repeated over and over in humanity
throughout history
the cycle of hatred
[Music]
and this loop is what aaron wants to
break why he so forcefully imposes the
notion that he is free to mikasa and
armin
because he believes and knows that
everyone else is inevitably succumbing
to the faults of humanity
the traits we have inherited from our
ancestors whether it's blood relations
like mikasa or the memories of
predecessors like armin
and so while yes i suppose aaron is
similarly free to zeke at this point
there's one small difference that i
think makes zeke's freedom so much more
dynamic
and tragic in a way it's that zeke has
always known this and let me explain
this a bit further
zeke was raised with the knowledge of
both truths of marlins and eldians
he would learn lessons from his
grandfather about these tales of libel
against
eldians and returned to his father later
that day to learn the real history
he grew up fully aware of the
undeserving suffering of
aldians and titan shifters it's
something that so many characters who
grew up in marley like gabby
aren't aware of they're so brainwashed
into the marlian system
somehow believing that they themselves
are devils
likewise the islanders were born and
bred solely on the idea of self-defense
of survival literally brainwashed this
time by the king within the walls and
weren't aware at all of the history of
the world
and the broader sense of things when you
look at it no one is wholly unbiased
and i think that this is the key in
defining whether you have free will
if you can defy fate and the path that
it set you on
kids and marley are indoctrinated into
the marlin way of thinking
even if you become a revolutionist like
grisha you develop an
intense and extreme hatred towards the
marlians who cruelly treated you
the islanders are just i mean they're
unaware of like anything
except what lies within the select miles
that encompass the walls
but zeke saw how the cycle of hatred
formed bubbled up within the elden
revolution and grisha
and betrayed his family instead of being
caught up in it
before he could be on either side of
this perpetual war
one that mainly deals in black and white
instead of grey you're either eldian or
your marlian
and you have to support one or the other
he broke free from the cycle at this
moment and from here on out
became what i can really only call alone
i think that this loneliness how peak
and his marlin comrades never knew what
zeke was planning and the survey core as
well
makes zeke's position in the world of
attack on titan so
important he is the perfect combination
of being neither
marlian nor eldian loyally following the
marlian regime while wanting to free the
aldians of their
pain always it takes someone who can
detach themselves from both sides like
what zeke has always done and what aaron
is doing now in season 4
to end this cycle and i think that's
what free will is an attack on titan the
ability to unchain yourself from your
friends
from biases and burdens that make you
favor someone else over another
it's a very cruel and dark twist on the
term
it's the free will to isolate yourself
from the norm
from the normal way of thinking that
keeps everyone locked in the birdcage
it's quite sad that while you're free
you're also left
isolated from everyone else the only
bird to escape from a broadcase with a
free world ahead of you
but no one to share it with it very much
so reflects the dark
almost fatalistic theme that attack on
titan has always divulged in
and this is why z shares or wants to
have such a deep natural bond with aaron
not necessarily just because they're
related or brothers
but because they both uniquely
understand this loneliness
aaron has cut off everyone in season 4
to reach this point
zeke never really had anyone to cut off
i guess grisha at the very beginning
these two who are thought of as gods by
elena who will rewrite history for
millennia to follow
are the two brothers who have freed
themselves from the shackles of
predisposed biases and hatred
zeke holds on to aaron because aaron is
the one person who not only could
understand his plan fully
but who zeke is and why he's done what
he has
but you also have to wonder why is
euthanization the best option
what has blossomed from zeke's free will
and individual purpose that led to this
idea
it's the burden he has endured his
entire life with the burden of knowledge
that led him to the euthanization plan
this is the other big difference that
blissful ignorance that most people an
attack on titan grew up knowing
or not knowing i guess granted living in
fear of titans isn't really blissful per
se
but compared to the genocide and war and
racism lying in wait once they escape
the island
i would honestly say it's a little bit
better
many of the eldins who live in marley
are blissfully ignorant of what they
could become
resigning themselves to being akin to
slaves and trash to marlians instead of
realizing that they're humans
but of course with zeke's childhood and
everything he didn't ever get this bliss
that both islanders and
aldians and marley got this inner peace
and i think this is why zeke came to
resent the idea of life itself
because he knows what life is really
like without that cloud of ignorance and
how cruel it can really be
the kind that forces you to betray your
parents the kind that makes you want to
commit mass
genocide against your race just to make
it all go away
the kind of life that makes you betray
all of your allies and have your own
plan
and walk a path of loneliness just for
the sake of peace
i think it's funny that the two
characters who are seemingly free
who should have escaped the cycle of
violence are both on a mission of mass
genocide of even more violence
that the best option for everyone is to
let the aldeans die with this generation
slowly and peacefully knowing that the
pain will be gone soon
the pain of life itself within the world
of attack on titan
what do you think did the last couple
episodes make you like zeke
even root for the euthanization plan i
know he's a much more interesting
character to me now and almost tragic in
a way
let me know what you think in the
comments down below as always this has
been the anime culture corner i hope you
enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses